Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. From whatever standpoint one regards it, the American Civil War presents a spectacle without parallel in the annals of military history. The vast extent of the disputed territory, the far-flung front of the lines of operation, the numerical
感谢收听《历史的 rest》节目。如需获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目的抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。无论从哪个角度来看，美国内战都在军事历史的编年史上呈现出一种无与伦比的奇观。争议领土的广袤无垠、作战路线战线之遥远、
strength of the hostile armies, the creation of which hardly drew any support from a prior organizational basis, the fabulous cost of these armies, the manner of commanding them, and the general tactical and strategic principles
敌对军队的兵力规模（其创建几乎没有得到先前组织基础的任何支持）、这些军队的惊人开销、指挥它们的方式，以及进行这场战争所依据的
in accordance with which the war is being waged. All these are new in the eyes of European undercutters. That, Dominic, was Karl Marx and, confusingly, Friedrich Engels. So I should actually have done that in stereo. You should have done. In a Manchester mill owner's accent surely in um in 1862 which of course second year of the american civil war uh it was like a kind of bloody stalemate at that point
一般战术和战略原则。在欧洲局势破坏者眼中，这一切都是崭新的。多米尼克，那是卡尔·马克思，容易混淆的是，还有弗里德里希·恩格斯。所以我其实应该用立体声来读那段。你本该这么做。用曼彻斯特工厂主的口音，当然是在嗯 1862 年，当然那是美国内战的第二年，呃，当时那就像是一种血腥的僵局，
um and the american civil war one of the great possibly the greatest theme in in american history but also in modern history more generally the sense that this is the beginning of something it's a kind of portent of so much that will happen in the late 19th and particularly in the 20th centuries so an amazing theme for but for this podcast it is it's an epic story tom um because a lot of people would probably say it's the first truly modern war because of course it has the telegraph and the railroad and it has a kind of sense of total mobilization um but also i think what makes the american civil war and i'm sure we'll come on to this so fascinating is that it has so many contemporary political and cultural kind of resonances so in some ways you could argue and we will definitely
嗯，而且美国内战是美国历史上、甚至可以说是更广泛的现代历史上最伟大、或许是最伟大的主题之一，那种这正是一切之开端的感知，它就像是对 19 世纪末尤其是 20 世纪将要发生之许多事情的一种预示，所以对于这个播客来说，这是一个绝佳的主题，汤姆，这是一个史诗般的故事，因为许多人可能会说，这是第一场真正意义上的现代战争，因为理所当然地，它拥有电报和铁路，并且有一种总体动员的感知，但同时，我认为使得美国内战如此迷人——而且我确信我们等会儿会谈到这一点——的是，它有着如此多的当代政治和文化共鸣，所以在某种程度上你可以争辩——而且我们稍后在本系列中也一定会
come to this later in this series that the american civil war is is as yet unresolved or the aftershocks of it are still rippling through american society and and from the point of view of how historians understand it obviously that is of seismic influence because it means that you know a settled opinion about it is pretty much impossible particularly perhaps at the moment anyway yeah but to get confirmation on that i think we need an absolutely top historian of the subject and i know dominique that this is i mean this is a subject very close to your heart this is something that you've studied that you know a lot about but it's very gracious of you that you have seeded the field to an even greater an even greater an
谈到这一点——美国内战至今尚未解决，或者说它的余波仍在美国社会中激荡，从历史学家如何理解它的角度来看，这显然具有震动般的影响，这意味着，你知道，要对它达成一个定论几乎是不可能的，特别是现在也许无论如何也做不到。是的，但为了证实这一点，我认为我们需要一位该领域的绝对顶级历史学家，多米尼克，我知道这——我的意思是，这是一个非常贴近你内心的主题，这是你研究过、了解很多的课题，但你能把这个舞台让位给一位更伟大、更伟大、更伟大的
even greater specialist so when we first started doing this podcast however many hundred episodes ago i'm we've mentioned doing guests and this was one of the very first people i thought of um because i have known this guest for more than 20 years he is professor adam smith the edward osborne professor of political history and director of the rothermere american institute at oxford i knew him when he was little more than a boy Tom and I think Adam Smith is the only historian uh with whom I pretended to be part of a couple to get into a bar in New York City do you remember that Adam I do remember that yes it was a piano bar I think it was I think I was more enthusiastic about this coupling than you were Dominic actually at the time I was you accused me at the time you
专家，真是太慷慨了。所以当我们在几百集以前刚开始做这个播客时，我就提到了邀请嘉宾，而这也是我最先想到的几个人之一，嗯，因为我认识这位嘉宾已经超过 20 年了，他就是亚当·史密斯教授，牛津大学爱德华·奥斯本政治史教授兼罗瑟米尔美国研究所所长。我认识他时，他 Tom，比一个小男孩大不了多少，而且我认为亚当·史密斯是唯一一位曾为了混进纽约市的一家酒吧而假装和我是一对情侣的历史学家。你还记得吗，亚当？我确实记得，是的，那是一家钢琴酒吧。我觉得我对这段恋情的狂热程度其实比你高，多米尼克，当时你指责我
said I was very unconvincing yeah um yeah couple that's very love island very very of the moment so it is fantastic what a wonderful so we were a very unconvincing couple but adam went on to great things at oxford and is a historian of lincoln the republican party the political scene during the american civil war so nobody better and tom best of all, Adam knows an enormous amount about American cricket. Well, which is a key part of the story, if not perhaps the key story. At some point, perhaps we can come on to that. But I wanted to kick off with a question really that's been posed by a gentleman currently resident in Florida, in Mar-a-Lago, former President Donald Trump, who – when was this, Dominic?
说我表现得非常不走心。是的，嗯，是的，情侣，这非常“爱情岛”（Love Island），非常切合时髦。所以这太棒了，多么美妙的经历啊。我们是一对非常没有说服力的情侣，但亚当后来在牛津成就了伟大事业，他是一位研究林肯、共和党以及美国内战期间政治局势的历史学家，所以没有人比他更合适了。汤姆，最棒的是，亚当对美国板球知之甚多。好吧，板球虽然可能不是最核心的故事，但它是故事的关键部分。在某个时候，也许我们可以谈谈这个。但我真正想从一个问题开始，这个问题是由目前住在佛罗里达州海湖庄园的一位绅士、前总统唐纳德·特朗普提出的——多米尼克，那是什时候的事？
It was a few years back, wasn't it? It was 2017, I think. 2017. If you think about it, why? People don't ask that question. But why was there the Civil War? Why could that one not have been worked out? That's Karl Marx's voice again, isn't it? it no that was donald trump i was clearly donald trump everyone would recognize that as donald
那是几年前的事了，对吧？我想是 2017 年。2017 年。如果你仔细想想，为什么？人们不会问这个问题。但为什么会发生内战？为什么那场战争就不能通过协商解决呢？那是卡尔·马克思的声音，对吧？不，那是唐纳德·特朗普。我显然是在模仿唐纳德·特朗普，每个人都会认出那是唐纳德·
trump um so so so adam um there you have it the president of the united states yeah it's saying that people don't ask the question of why did the civil war happen yeah um so as a professor at Oxford, why aren't you asking this question? Yeah, no, it never occurred to me why it happened. I mean, in fairness, I mean, there were there is a lot. There have been a lot of people throughout throughout American history over the last 150 years who said, surely we could have avoided that one. I mean, there is a tradition underlying. Do you think they're right? Do you think they're right? No, I think they're completely wrong.
特朗普。所以，所以，所以，亚当，嗯，你瞧，美国总统在说，人们不会去追问为什么会爆发内战这个问题，嗯，作为牛津大学的教授，你为什么不问这个问题呢？对啊，不，我从来没想过它为什么会发生。我的意思是，平心而论，嗯，有很多人。在过去的 150 年里，整个美国历史上有很多人都说过，我们本来肯定是可以避免那场战争的。我的意思是，有一种潜在的传统。你觉得他们说得对吗？你觉得他们对吗？不，我认为他们完全大错特错。
I think this is an interesting example in modern history of a war that it's, I mean, we can play some interesting alternative history games and try and imagine scenarios in which a war could have been avoided. You can imagine how a different war could have been fought, but it's pretty hard to imagine how the fundamental moral and political and economic problem of slavery could have been resolved in the United States in any way short of some kind of big breakdown. And so in that sense, is it the case that the American Civil War is baked into the original founding of the United States? Yeah, I think it's as close to being that as anything you'll find. I mean, this is not like the First World War in Europe, where you can imagine all kinds of different scenarios, all kinds of things had to be in place for that war to happen in the way that it did in North America in 1861 was one that had been predicted and foreordained and speculated about and people had had nightmares about it. And some people had looked forward to it, right, because it was imagined correctly, as it turned out, by abolitionists, by anti-slavery activists of all stripes to be the most likely way, given the institutional structure of the United States, that you could ever bring about the end of slavery. So it would have been much anticipated. And then it came.
我认为这是现代历史上一个有趣的例子，关于一场——我的意思是，我们可以玩一些有趣的另类历史游戏，试着想象一场本可避免战争的情景。你可以想象一场不同的战争是如何打的，但很难想象奴隶制这种根本性的道德、政治和经济问题，怎么可能在美国以除了某种巨大崩溃之外的任何方式得到解决。所以从这个意义上说，美国内战是不是已经深深烙印在美国最初的建国之本中了？是的，我认为这是你能找到的最接近这一说法的存在。我的意思是，这不像欧洲的第一次世界大战，你可以想象各种不同的情景，需要具备各种各样的条件，那场战争才会像它在 1861 年北美发生的那样爆发。那是一场早已被预测、预言、揣测过的战争，人们曾对它做过噩梦。有些人甚至对它充满期待，对吧，因为它被废奴主义者、各色反奴隶制活动人士正确地想象成——事实也证明如此——鉴于美国的制度结构，这是你结束奴隶制的唯一最可能的方式。所以它是被热切期盼的。然后它就爆发了。
So let's go back to the very beginning then, Adam. I mean, whether that very beginning of 1619 or 1776 is now a subject of intemperate debate, isn't it? But let's go back to 1776 anyway. So the United States of America are founded. They declare independence from the colonists, break away from Great Britain. Some of them have slavery, and some of them don't. And they sort of muddle along into the beginning of the 19th century, don't they? But even point so with you know when the when the republic is celebrating its 10th 20th 30th birthdays are people conscious then that slavery is this sort of ticking time bomb um that's going to engulf them all yeah they are now in fairness there are other potential ticking time bombs that people imagine are there that don't go off so people
那么让我们回到最初，亚当。我的意思是，无论是 1619 年还是 1776 年的那个最初起点，现在都成了激烈争论的话题，不是吗？但无论如何，我们还是回到 1776 年。美利坚合众国建国了。他们宣布独立于殖民者，脱离大不列颠。他们当中有些州蓄奴，有些州不蓄奴。他们就这样磕磕绊绊地进入了 19 世纪初，对吧？但甚至在这个时候——你知道的，当共和国庆祝它成立 10 周年、20 周年、30 周年生日时，人们当时是否意识到奴隶制是一种即将吞噬他们所有人的定时炸弹？嗯，他们意识到了。现在，平心而论，人们还想象存在其他潜在的定时炸弹，但并没有引爆，所以人们
imagine there's might be a ticking time bomb a division between western states and eastern states there are other potential lines of division but um but everybody knew uh that that slavery was probably the the critical factor i would say it's not 1776 so much as 1787 or 1789 that really matters. 1787 was when the Constitutional Convention met and 1789 was when the Constitution came into effect. And that new constitution, which created a stronger federal government, created a national government really for the for the first time, could not have been put together, would not have been agreed by all of the 13 states as they then were, the previously 13 colonies that had broken away from the British Empire, could not have been agreed by them had it not been for the fact that there was a conscious compromise over the question of slavery. So as you say, Dominic, by then, by the late 1780s, slavery was kind of on the way out in New England. There were moves already being made in the middle,
想象可能会存在一个定时炸弹，即西部各州和东部各州之间的分裂，还有其他潜在的分裂线，但是，嗯，每个人都知道，奴隶制可能才是那个最关键的因素。我要说的是，与其说是 1776 年，不如说是 1787 年或 1789 年真正重要。1787 年制宪会议召开，1789 年宪法正式生效。这部新宪法建立了一个更强大的联邦政府，真正意义上第一次建立了一个国家级政府，如果不是因为对奴隶制问题做出了自觉的妥协，它是根本拼凑不起来的，也不会得到当时所有的 13 个州——即先前脱离大不列颠帝国的 13 个殖民地——的一致同意。所以正如你所说，多米尼克，到那时，即 18 世纪 80 年代末，在英格兰新教地区，奴隶制已经在走向消亡。中部地区，
in the mid-Atlantic states, in Pennsylvania, in New York, in New Jersey, to put slavery on the course of ultimate extinction, to use a phrase that Abraham Lincoln would later reiterate again and again and again. And in the more southernmost states, Virginia being by far the most populous, slavery seemed so central to the economy that it was much harder to imagine how slavery would end. Yet even there, there was a sense that, well, maybe it's a legacy of a previous era. Maybe something will happen in the next few decades that will make it less important to us to have to hold on to it. So for the time being, it was necessary to reassure southern slaveholders that this new national government was not going to have the power to end slavery in their southern states. But at the same time, northerners and anti-slavery mid-Atlantic people were able to join this national government in the optimistic hope that maybe by about 1810, maybe by 1850, who knew, slavery would probably have disappeared in the
在大西洋中部各州，如宾夕法尼亚州、纽约州、新泽西州，已经开始采取行动，让奴隶制走向最终消亡，用亚伯拉罕·林肯后来一次又一次重复的话来说。而在更靠南的各州，弗吉尼亚州无疑人口最多，奴隶制似乎对经济至关重要，以至于更难想象奴隶制将如何结束。然而，即便在那里，人们也有一种感觉：嗯，也许这只是一个时代的遗留产物。也许在未来几十年里会发生某些事情，让我们觉得保留它没那么重要了。所以暂且不论，有必要向南方的蓄奴者保证，这个新的国家政府将没有权力终结他们南方各州的奴隶制。但与此同时，北方人和大西洋中部的反奴隶制人士得以加入这个国家政府，并抱着一种乐观的希望：也许到 1810 年左右，也许到 1850 年，谁知道呢，奴隶制大概会在
south anyway, just as it was already disappearing in the northeast and the mid-Atlantic. So Adam, why is slavery seen as a problem? I mean, that sounds an insane question from our perspective. But for people in the late 18th century, it's not at all a given that slavery as an institution is morally wrong. So in the context of the nascent United States, is it Christian principles that are causing this tension? Or is it the sense that there is a measure of hypocrisy in the kind of Jeffersonian preaching of liberty, while at the same time holding human beings in bondage? Or is it a kind of fusion of both or something more? It's definitely both of those things, Tom. I mean,
南方自行消失，就像它已经在中国东北和大西洋中部消失那样。那么亚当，为什么奴隶制被视为一个问题？我的意思是，从我们的角度来看，这听上去是个荒谬的问题。但对于 18 世纪末的人们来说，奴隶制作为一种制度在道德上是错误的，这绝非理所当然。那么在初生的美国的背景下，是基督教原则导致了这种紧张局势吗？还是因为人们觉得，杰斐逊式的高谈阔论自由的同时，却将人类囚禁在奴役之中，这里面带有某种虚伪？或者它是两者的一种融合，抑或是更深的东西？汤姆，这绝对是这两种因素兼而有之。我的意思是，
it's the famous line from Dr. Johnson, isn't there? Why do we hear the loudest yelps for freedom from the drivers of Negroes? I mean, the answer to that question that some historians have put forward is that we hear the loudest yelps for freedom precisely because they're the drivers of Negroes, to quote Johnson. In other words, the presence of actual chattel slavery sharpened colonial american sense of the distinction between freedom and slavery um but but yes it was by the late 18th century of course there was a growing anti-slavery movement in in britain as well as in north america um and of course the the language the enlightenment, which informed the Declaration of Independence, these ringing declarations of the equality of man,
就是约翰逊博士的那句名言，不是吗？为什么我们听到对自由最响亮的呐喊，来自于那些黑奴的驾驭者？我的意思是，一些历史学家提出的对这个问题的回答是，我们之所以听到对自由最响亮的呐喊，恰恰因为他们就是黑奴的驾驭者，借用约翰逊的话说。换句话说，实际动产奴隶制的存留，加剧了殖民地美国人对自由与奴隶制之间区别的感知。但是，是的，到 18 世纪末，当然，不仅在北美，在英国也出现了一个日益壮大的反奴隶制运动，而且当然，
you don't need to look back on that retrospectively to see the obvious disjuncture between those claims and the reality of the claim to property and man. But, Adam, you were saying that people thought slavery might wither away. But as the 19th century progresses, I mean, it would seem to me that two things happen. One is that the world demand for cotton
启蒙运动的语言——它构成了《独立宣言》的基础，那些关于人人平等的铿锵宣言——你不需要回过头去回顾它，就能看出这些主张与对人类财产权的主张这一现实之间存在着明显的脱节。但是，亚当，你刚才说人们曾以为奴隶制可能会自行消亡。但随着 19 世纪的推进，我的意思是，在我看来有两件事发生了。一是世界对棉花的需求
increases massively. You have the development of the cotton gin. The South is producing about a quarter of the world's cotton, I think, by 1860. So the institution, the economic institution is making a lot of people a lot of the world's cotton, I think, by 1860. So the institution, the economic institution, is making a lot of people a lot of money. It's obviously deeply embedded in the cultural world as well, isn't it? It's like cotton to the 19th century industrial economy
急剧增加。轧棉机问世了。到 1860 年，南方生产的棉花大约占世界总产量的四分之一，我想。因此，这一制度，这一经济制度正在为许多人——世界棉花产量的很大一部分，我想，到 1860 年。所以这一制度，这一经济制度，正在为许多人带来大量财富。它显然也深深植根于文化世界中，不是吗？就像棉花对于 19 世纪工业经济的意义
is like oil is to the mid-20th century. And by 1860, raw cotton from the American South, it's about 90% of the imports of raw cotton into Britain, in fact, are coming from the American South. So they're like the kind of the Middle East on this kind of oil analogy. And the price of cotton keeps on rising, as you say, through the 1830s and 40s and 50s, and the capacity to produce cotton in large quantities increases and then the critical factor here that we'll talk about which is the territorial expansion of the united states means that there's just hundreds of thousands of acres uh under cultivation growing cotton more than there was uh at the at the beginning of the of the period so so yeah a lot of people are making a lot of money from it and
一样，犹如石油对于 20 世纪中叶的意义。到 1860 年，来自美国南部的原棉，事实上大约占英国原棉进口量的 90% 都来自美国南部。所以他们就像是这种石油类比中的“中东”。而且如你所说，在 1830 年代、40 年代和 50 年代，棉花价格不断上涨，大规模生产棉花的能力也不断增强。然后，这里有一个我们将要讨论的关键因素，即美国的领土扩张，这意味着有成百上千英亩的土地被开垦用来种植棉花，比该时期刚开始时要多得多。所以，是的，很多人正从中赚取巨额财富，
well that's what i wanted to ask about the territorial expansion because actually when you look at american i mean the build the build- up to all civil wars is fascinating in Spain and Yugoslavia, in America, as much as anywhere. There's an awful lot of violence in the build up to the American Civil War. There's paramilitary violence, there's assassinations and so on. But in particular, I mean, there's this violence that the Americans themselves are sort of dealing out to others. So most famously, I suppose, Mexico. So the Mexican-American War, they take Texas or they absorb Texas and then they defeat Mexico 1846 to 48. And is that, to me, I would say, and now maybe I'm completely wrong because it's years since I really thought about this. But to me, that feels like one of the absolute triggers for what comes because the acquisition of so much territory from Mexico. Totally.
这正是我想要问的关于领土扩张的问题，因为实际上当你审视美国时——我的意思是，所有内战前的蓄势都是引人入胜的，无论是西班牙、南斯拉夫还是美国，都同样如此。在美国内战前的蓄势阶段，存在着大量的暴力。有准军事暴力、暗杀等等。但特别是，我的意思是，有一种暴力是美国人自己施加给别人的。所以最著名的，我想就是墨西哥。因此，美墨战争中，他们夺取了得克萨斯，或者说他们吞并了得克萨斯，然后在 1846 年至 1848 年击败了墨西哥。这——在我看来，也许我现在完全错了，因为我已经好几年没真正思考过这个问题了——但在我看来，这感觉就像是引发后来一切的绝对导火索之一，因为他们从墨西哥获得了如此庞大的领土。完全是这样。
And that war was probably the most successful war of territorial expansion in modern history. Very, very small number of Americans were killed, and yet they had this huge expansion of territory, all of Southern California, New Mexico, Arizona, all of that big southwest portion of the United States came into the United States after the defeat of Mexico. And the problem then was,
那场战争可能是现代历史上最成功的领土扩张战争。极少数美国人阵亡，然而他们却获得了巨大的领土扩张，整个南加州、新墨西哥州、亚利桑那州，美国西南部的那大片区域，在击败墨西哥后都并入了美国。而当时的问题是，
should slavery be legal or illegal in those territories? It had been illegal in Mexico. So the question is whether you push slavery into this new area. And the people really pushing this territorial war of expansion were slaveholders, and they wanted that southwestern territory in order to grow more cotton, take more enslaved people there. So essentially, just to be clear, because this is a really dumb question, but slavery is geographically determined because cotton is geographically determined. It's determined by the climate.
在这些领土上，奴隶制应该是合法的还是非法的？在墨西哥，它一直是非法的。所以问题在于，你是否将奴隶制推向这个新地区。而真正推动这场领土扩张战争的人是蓄奴者，他们想要这片西南部领土是为了种植更多棉花，把更多的被奴役人口带到那里去。所以基本上，为了说清楚——因为这是一个非常愚蠢的问题——奴隶制是由地理决定的，因为棉花是由地理决定的。它是由气候决定的。
Is that essentially why it's so much more fundamental to the Southern economy than it ever was to the Northern? Yes, it becomes very tied with cotton. In the 18th century it wasn't so and that's what you know there were enslaved people in boston townhouses and uh but in the end the reason why slavery became a southern institution was because was overwhelmingly because of cotton also also tobacco and and rice and sugar but overwhelmed but overwhelmingly overwhelmingly cotton and so the but though, Tom, also meant that there
这基本上就是为什么它对南方经济远比对北方经济更具根本性的原因吗？是的，它与棉花紧密相连。在 18 世纪并非如此，你知道的，波斯顿的城镇住宅里也有被奴役的人，但最终，奴隶制之所以成为南方的一种制度，绝大多数是因为棉花。当然还有烟草、水稻和糖，但绝大多数——压倒性地——是棉花。因此，虽然如此，汤姆，这也意味着在内战后随后的几十年里，美国有一些人说，正因为如此，正因为棉花和奴隶制之间存在这种联系，我们不需要对这个问题过于担心，因为奴隶制永远不可能成为一种全国性的制度。它不太可能在堪萨斯等地真正扎根。对，对。因为堪萨斯似乎并不具备适合棉花种植的气候。所以，当我们开放新州堪萨斯时，为什么还要担心我们是否应该禁止那里的奴隶制呢？但正是这一点决定了为什么它是南方与北方，而不是东西方向或
were some people in the United States in the decades running after the Civil War who said, well, because that's true, because there is that association between cotton and slavery, we don't need to worry about this too much because slavery can never become a national institution. It's unlikely ever to take hold critically in Kansas, for example. Right, right. Because Kansas doesn't appear to have the appropriate climate for cotton cultivation. So why worry then about whether we ban slavery from the new state of kansas when it was opened up but it's it's that that determines why it's north and south and not say east and west or yes any other configuration and that is why the acquisition of states along
任何其他配置，这也是为什么沿那条边界地带的领土收购会成为特殊的爆发点。是的，是的，但是亚当，所以对于那些刚接触这一主题的人来说，我猜问题在于，好吧，他们对奴隶制有分歧——你知道的，非常非常简单地说，北方和南方对奴隶制有分歧，但问题不止于此，对吧？因为它是如此具有煽动性，因为在北方，他们有一种阴谋论的想法，认为一个“蓄奴势力”（slave power）的存在正在破坏美国本身；而在南方，
that kind of border zone become particular flashpoints yes yes but but adam so so for people who who are new to this i i suppose the question is okay they disagree about slavery you know i mean very very simplistically north and south disagree about slavery but there's more to the issue than that isn't there because it's so incendiary because in the north they have this idea of a conspiracy a slave power that is the very existence of slavery is undermining the united states itself in the south um you know there is this sort of that the institution of keeping you know so many people enslaved has bred a kind of a weird kind of paranoia hasn't it and a sort of there's a there's a violence to the debate
你知道，有这样一种观点：囚禁如此多被奴役之人的制度，孕育了一种奇怪的偏执，不是吗？而且辩论中带有一种暴力色彩，这对于局外人来说可能显得有点奇怪，因为你可能会说，好吧，他们如果想蓄奴就让他们蓄奴呗，为什么你认为它变得如此积怨深重呢？这是为了挑出——我正要说的是汤姆最喜欢的主题之一，毫无疑问，汤姆最喜欢的主题就是，这最终在某种程度上是一场宗教辩论，或者说它充满了宗教色彩？它充满了——我的意思是，19世纪的一切都充满了宗教色彩。但它也充满了关于美国是什么、美国人是谁、以及这将是一个什么样的共和国的问题。归根结底，问题在于，对于北方人来说，对于那些生活在奴隶制非法的各州的人来说，问题在于
which to people outside it might seem a bit odd because you might say well why don't they just let if they want to have slaves let them have slaves why do you think it becomes so embittered now is that i mean to pick one of that well i was about to say one of tom's favorite themes undoubtedly tom's favorite theme is that because this is ultimately a religious debate to some degree, or it's infused with religiosity? It is infused with, I mean, everything in the 19th century is infused with religiosity. But it's also infused with the question of what America is and who Americans are and what kind of republic this is going to be. And in the end, the question is whether for northerners, for people who live in states where slavery is illegal, the question is
南方奴隶制的体制是否正在腐蚀整个共和国，从而最终侵蚀了他们作为白人美国公民的自由。正是在那个时刻，当马萨诸塞州或伊利诺伊州的北方人认为南方蓄奴者提出的要求正在剥夺他们自身的自由时，局势变得非常、非常危险。我认为，正是到了那个时候，战争
whether the institution of slavery in the South is corrupting the republic as a whole, and in the end, therefore, infringing their freedom as white American citizens. And it's when it gets to that moment, when Northerners in Massachusetts or Illinois think that the demands being made by Southern slaveholders are such that their own freedoms are being abridged. That's the point where it becomes really, really dangerous. And when war,
变得不可避免。我的意思是，关于奴隶制，你可以说奴隶制是美国内战的原因，对吧？但这等于什么都没说，又什么都说了。我的意思是，问题在于，奴隶制是如何导致战争的？当你跟那些否认奴隶制是战争原因的美国人交谈时（你知道，“那场战争跟奴隶制无关”），当你问人们——我清晰地记得 90 年代我在美国时，曾去参观南卡罗来纳州的一座种植园宅邸。那个穿着克里诺林裙（crinoline）的导游女士带我们参观完奴隶寮舍等等之后，
I think becomes unavoidable. I mean, the thing about slavery is you can say slavery was the cause of the American Civil War, right? And that is to say, you know, everything and nothing. I mean, the question is, how was slavery? How did slavery come to create the war? And when you talk to Americans who deny that slavery was the cause of the war, you know, that war is not about slavery. And you ask people, I mean, I vividly remember one of the times when I was in the States back in the 90s and I took a tour around one of those plantation houses in South Carolina. And the crinoline lady showing us around and after she'd shown us, she had shown us the slave quarters and so on.
她给我们讲解了房间里所有照片和家具的年代。当时我和一群戴着棒球帽的美国人在一起。有一刻，你知道的，那位穿克里诺林裙的女士说：“不，那场战争与奴隶制无关。”那么问题来了，如果那场战争与奴隶制无关，那它是关于什么的？她会说，那场战争是关于“各州的权力”（states' rights）。但是，当然，对南方人至关重要的“各州权力”，是他们保护奴隶制的权力。当南方蓄奴者在内战前夕
And she was telling us the dates of all the pictures and the furniture in the room. And I was there with a group of Americans in baseball caps. And at one point, you know, the crinoline lady said, no, that war is not about slavery. And the question then is, you know, what was the war about if it wasn't about slavery? What she would have said was that war was about states' rights. But, of course, the states' rights that mattered to Southerners were their right to protect slavery. And when it became necessary for Southern slaveholders
变得有必要利用国家政府来执行“人类财产权”原则时，他们毫不犹豫地动用了国家政府。1850 年的《逃亡奴隶法》（Fugitive Slave Act）就是联邦权力的一次巨大扩张。正是在那之后，北方的各州开始谈论“各州权力”，以抵抗联邦权力的侵犯，因为联邦权力将手伸进了北方自由州的社区，不经当地陪审团、当地警察局或当地法院的程序，就逮捕并用铁链拖走了逃亡奴隶，或者蓄奴者声称是逃亡奴隶的人。那是联邦权力的大规模扩张，而且它是被支持的，蓄奴者必须这样要求。所以归根结底，一切都离不开奴隶制。但正如你所说，多米尼克，它与关于共和自由的这些基本问题完全交织在一起，正如北方人和南方人所理解的那样。而在北方，他们周围并没有奴隶。那么他们又是如何被激进化的呢？林肯——
in the run-up to the Civil War to use the national government in order to enforce the principle of property and man, then they had no hesitation in using the national government. The 1850 Fugitive Slave Act was a big expansion of federal power. And it was in the aftermath of that, it was northern states who were talking about states' rights in order to resist the encroachment of the federal government who were reaching in to northern free state communities and arresting and dragging away in chains fugitive slaves or people who slaveholders claimed had been fugitives from slavery without recourse to local juries or local
林肯据说是见过了——呃，哈丽雅特·比彻·斯托（Harriet Beecher Stowe），对吧？还说“你就是那个引发了这么大一场战争的小妇人”或者类似的话，用《汤姆叔叔的小屋》引发了这么大一场战争，是吗？像《汤姆叔叔的小屋》这样的书、弗雷德里克·道格拉斯（Frederick Douglass）的言论，所有这些都在发挥作用吗？
police forces or local courts. That was a massive expansion of federal power and it was supported, it was necessary for slaveholders to demand it. So it all comes back to slavery one way or another. But as you say, Dominic, it's completely interlaced with all these basic questions about Republican freedom, as Northerners and Southerners understood those things. And in the North, they're not surrounded by slaves. So how are they kind of being radicalized so lincoln lincoln is supposed to have met um uh harriet beecher stowe isn't he and said you're the little lady who made such a big war or something made such a big war with um uncle tom's cabin yeah was our our novels like uncle tom's cabin frederick douglas's kind of, all this kind of thing, is this having an effect?
还是说，这更多只是一种他们在报纸上读到的东西、人们在谈论的东西的感知？这种激进化过程是如何发生的？它显然发挥了作用。我的意思是，《汤姆叔叔的小屋》是一部出版轰动之作，而《汤姆叔叔的小屋》所做的是，将一种分裂家庭、在各个意义上侵犯女性、从而违背了维多利亚时代基督教原则的奴役制度的现实，带入了中产阶级、维多利亚中期的东北部美国家庭的视野中。
Or is it more just a kind of sense of what they're reading in the newspapers, what people are saying? How is this process of radicalization happening? So it clearly does have an effect. I mean, Uncle Tom's Cabin was a publishing sensation. sensation and what uncle tom's cabin does is to put into the homes of middle-class mid-victorian northeastern americans confront them with the reality of a system of enslavement that breaks up families that violates women in every sense so violates christian principles in the victorian sense exactly and that gets people and it's one of the reasons why women are so important in the anti-slavery movement um frederick douglas this incredibly articulate amazing baritone voice
正是这一点触动了人们，这也是为什么女性在废奴运动中如此重要，嗯。弗雷德里克·道格拉斯——那个口齿极其伶俐、拥有惊人男中音嗓音、极其有效的演讲者、优秀的作家，生为奴隶，从马里兰州的奴隶制中逃脱——他成为了一个极具代表性的代言人，打破了“黑人天生就是奴隶”的迷信，从而将这种现实摆在了白人北方人面前。但归根结底，我不认为——我的意思是，那种反奴隶制的言论不会把美国推向战争，我想，如果不是因为人们在北方他们自己的街道和社区里所能看到和亲身经历的事情的话。我认为我刚刚提到的 1850 年的《逃亡奴隶法》，可能是触发美国内战的最重要的单独立法。
incredibly effective speaker good writer born into slavery escaped from slavery in maryland he becomes this very visible spokesman for the possibility that well you know what black people are not clearly not born somehow born innately into slavery and so confronts white northerners with that reality. But in the end, I don't think, I mean, those kinds of anti-slavery arguments would not have driven the United States to war, I don't think, were it not for what people could see and experience in their own streets and their own communities in the north. I think the Fugitive Slave Act of 1850, which I just mentioned, is probably the single most important piece of legislation in helping to trigger the American Civil War.
我的意思是，那里面有很多竞争者。还有 1854 年的《堪萨斯-内布拉斯加法案》（Kansas-Nebraska Act）。还有其他我们可以讨论的事情。但为了论证起见，我把赌注押在 1850 年的《逃亡奴隶法》上。这是因为你可以亲眼看到自由的黑人男女被强行拖走。是的。而且有一个著名的、或许也是最臭名昭著的案例，就是 1854 年在波士顿的安东尼·伯恩斯（Anthony Burns）事件，这个家伙实际上是一个逃亡奴隶，已经在布拉特尔街（Brattle Street）生活、
I mean, there's a lot of competition there. There's also the Kansas-Nebraska Act of 1854. And there are other things we could talk about. But for the sake of argument, I put my money on the 1850 Fugitive Slave Act. And that's because you can see free black men and women being physically dragged away in front of your eyes. Yeah. And there's the famous, perhaps the most notorious case was that of Anthony Burns in Boston in 1854, where this guy who was in fact a fugitive slave who'd been living in,
工作了几个月，结果被联邦武装逮捕并带走，戴着铁链游街示众，押往波士顿港。当他被强行押上一艘联邦船只并被带回南方时，波士顿的教堂钟声敲响了。当然，在革命的摇篮里，这是对自由的一次显而易见的践踏。所以他后来怎么样了？对安东尼·伯恩斯来说是个好消息，他——他被卖回给了北方人，也就是反奴隶制人士，他们有效地拯救了他，他在 1862 年去世了。哦，好吧，那——结局比可能发生的最坏情况要好。所以还有许多其他人，他们的故事并没有那么好的结局。当然，我想多聊聊南方。所以北方正因《逃亡奴隶法》、小册子、书籍和演讲等因素而走向激进化，但我的看法对吗：南方其实也在某种程度上走向了激进化？我有一种感觉，也许我完全记错了，那就是南方人对奴隶制的一两代人之前的态度曾认为它是一种“虽令人遗憾但不可避免的恶”。
working in Brattle Street for a few months, was arrested by federal forces and taken, marched in chains to the port of Boston. And the bells of Boston tolled as he was forced onto a federal ship and taken back down south. And this, of course, in the cradle of the revolution, this very visible violation of liberty. so what happened to him it was a good news story for anthony burns he he was he was sold back to northerners to anti-slavery people who who effectively rescued him and he he died in in 1862 oh well that's that's that ended better than it could have done so there were many others for whom
然而与之相对的是一种感觉，对吧，他们在 1850 年代对奴隶制彻底着迷，将其视为一种“积极的善”（positive good）、视为他们自身的高贵、传统以及所有那些在残酷、机械化的资本主义北方中丧失的美好事物的象征。是的，是的，完全正确。而且我认为这种转变发生在大约 1820 年代末或 1830 年代初，所以它与北方激进废奴运动的兴起是同步发生的。
the story did not end so yeah of course well i wanted to talk a little bit about the south so the north is becoming radicalized i suppose by by the fugitive slave act and by pamphlets and books and speeches and so on but am i right in thinking the south is also becoming radicalized in a way i i sort of get a sense and maybe I'm completely misremembering this, that the southerners' attitude to slavery a generation or two earlier had been that it was a kind of regrettable but necessary evil.
这是极化现象发生的经典方式，双方都在对彼此做出反应。然而在 1820 年代末，在弗吉尼亚州议会里，例如，辩论一项渐进式解放法案仍然是可能的；但到了 1830 年代末，这已经完全不可想象了。到 1830 年代末，南方已经没有任何空间容纳任何白人或任何质疑奴隶制道德正确性的人了。但是亚当，据推测——我的意思是，南方究竟有多大比例的人口实际上从奴隶制中获利？
Whereas there's a sense, isn't there, that they're absolutely obsessed with slavery in the 1850s, and they see it as a positive good, as a sign of their own nobility and their tradition and their these all these wonderful things that have been lost in the cruel mechanistic capitalistic north yeah yeah that's absolutely right and i think that that transition happens around the late 1820s or early 1830s and so it happens in line with the rise of radical abolitionist movements in the North. It's
直接拥有被奴役人口意义上的那种奴隶制，大约只有四分之一。所以这里有一个重大而有趣的问题：为什么大多数并不直接受益于奴隶所有权的南方白人，依然支持
the classic way in which polarization happens and that each is reacting to the other. And whereas in the late 1820s, it's still possible in the Virginia state legislature, for example, to debate a gradual emancipation bill, by the end of the 1830s, that is completely inconceivable. There's no space in the South by the end of the 1830s for any white person or anybody questioning the moral rectitude of slavery. But Adam, presumably, I mean, what proportion of people in the South actually are profiting from slavery? slavery in in the direct sense of owning uh enslaved people it's only about a quarter um so there is a is a big and interesting question here about why the majority of white southerners who don't themselves directly benefit from the ownership of slaves nevertheless support the
蓄奴制度？据我们所知，他们大多数人确实如此。而且他们在适当的时候愿意为之牺牲。归根结底，他们愿意为之牺牲，或者至少愿意为了一个拥有奴隶的社会而牺牲，而不是向他们眼中的“扬基枷锁”（Yankee yoke）低头。一个显而易见的答案是，奴隶制的存在创造了一个种族等级制度，所以如果你是一个贫穷的、没有财产的白人男性，你至少知道你永远不会被正式奴隶化，这就基于你的肤色赋予了你一种在非蓄奴社会中不会拥有的地位。尽管如此——我的意思是，南方有很多地方似乎并不成立这一点，在南方的一些地方，奴隶并不多，因为黑人也不多（比如北卡罗来纳州北部山区等等），
slave system which so far as we can tell, most of them did. And are willing to die for it in due course. And in the end, are willing to die for it, or at least willing to die for a society which has slavery rather than submit to the Yankee yoke, as they would see it. And an obvious answer is that the existence of slavery creates a racial caste system and so if you're a poor propertyless white man you at least know that you can never be formally enslaved and so that gives you a kind of status on the basis of your skin color which you wouldn't have in a non-slave based society um that there are i mean there are plenty of places in the south where that doesn't really
而这些地方并非巧合地成了南方对为邦联（Confederacy）作战最不热情、美国内战期间逃兵率最高的地方。在 1850 年代末，有几个相当高调的南方白人，其中最突出的就是欣顿·罗恩·赫尔珀（Hinton Rowan Helper），他写了一本书，指出奴隶制真正的问题在于它对贫困白人造成的影响。这本书一经出版，他就被赶出了南方，当然；
seem to hold true and in parts of the south where there aren't very many enslaved people because there aren't many black people up country north carolina and so on um those are not coincidentally the parts of the south which are least enthusiastic about fighting for the confederacy and where desertion during the american civil war is at its highest rates. And there were a couple of quite high-profile white Southerners in the late 1850s, the most prominent being Hinton Rowan Helper, who wrote a book saying the real problem with slavery is what it does to poor white people. And this was taken up, and he was then hounded out of the South, of course,
但这本书被北方的反奴隶制人士欣喜若狂地采纳了，因为它完美地证明了他们的论点。奴隶制的问题在于它对其他人造成的影响——即使对被奴役的人有影响（如果在某些情况下真的有的话），它对所有人造成的影响才是关键：它腐蚀了奴隶主，并使那些不拥有奴隶的人变得贫困。所以你可以在北方成为一个废奴主义者，但同时仍然是个极其严重种族主义者？绝对是的。你几分钟前说过，汤姆，北方人是在周围没有奴隶的环境中长大的，他们中的许多人也是在周围没有黑人的环境中长大的。他们生活中的实际经验是，他们生活在一个纯净的白人共和国里，
but this book was taken up by Northern anti-slavery people with great glee because it made their case for them exactly. The problem with slavery is what it does, not just, if at all, in some cases, to enslave people, but what it does to everybody else. The way it corrupts the owners of slaves and the way it impoverishes those who don't own slaves. So you can be an abolitionist in the north and still be massively racist? Definitely. You know said a um a few minutes ago tom that you northerners were growing up without slavery around them many of them were also growing up without black people around them they were living their their actual experience was that they were living in a kind of lily white whites white man's republic and that, you know, the gender and the race bit of that is important.
而且，你知道的，其中的性别和种族成分非常重要。亚伯拉罕·林肯就是一个很好的例子。我的意思是，在伊利诺伊州，他作为青少年搬到那里并建立了自己的事业和政治生涯，伊利诺伊州的法条中其实有反黑人法律，所以黑人搬到伊利诺伊州实际上是违法的。奴隶制在伊利诺伊州是非法的，但同样，黑人也是非法的。我的意思是，伊利诺伊州尽管如此还是有一个黑人社区，但非常小。这就引发了关于“殖民”（colonization）的问题，亚当，这绝对是一个引人入胜的话题，可能很多人并不知道。也就是说，林肯就是一个很好的例子——我们将在中场休息后更深入地谈谈林肯——但林肯就是一个很好的例子，不是吗？他是一个痛恨奴隶制、希望看到它被根除的人，但基本上在一个理想的世界里，他也希望看到大量的非裔美国人，甚至可能几乎全部或确实所有的非裔美国人，
And Abraham Lincoln is a good example. I mean, in the state of Illinois, where he moves as a kind of teenager and builds his career and his political career in the end, Illinois has anti-black laws on the on on the book so it's actually illegal for black people to move to illinois slavery is illegal in illinois but as it were so are black people i mean there is nevertheless a black community in illinois but it's very small so that raises the issue about colonization adam which is absolutely fascinating probably a lot of people don't know about which is that i mean lincoln is a good example we'll come to lincoln more properly after the break but lincoln is a good example isn't he of somebody who hates slavery wants to see it extirpated but also basically in an ideal world would like to see huge numbers of african-americans perhaps almost all or indeed all african-americans
被实际驱逐到非洲去。是的，亚伯拉罕·林肯所支持的“美国殖民协会”（American Colonization Society），这正是他们声称的目标：通过将黑人移出美国来结束奴隶制。在不同的时期，美国殖民协会得到了政治建制派的支持——各种层级、不同类型的政治建制派，在整个 1810 年代、20 年代和 30 年代，几乎在深南部以外的任何地方都得到了支持。我的意思是，你提到托马斯·杰斐逊在这方面也很有趣。
physically moved to africa yeah yes and the American Colonization Society which Abraham Lincoln is a supporter of that that is their stated aim to end slavery by removing black people from America and at various points that the American Colonization Society has the support of the political establishment as it were the multiple layers different types of the political establishment, as it were, the multiple layers, different types of the political establishment, pretty much everywhere outside of the Deep South through the 1810s and 20s and 30s. I mean, you talk about, I mean, Thomas Jefferson is interesting in this respect as well.
我的意思是，杰斐逊，《独立宣言》的作者，“人人生而平等”，他本人也是一个蓄奴者，内心深感纠结，意识到了奴隶制将像他这样的人置于何等可怕的束缚之中。当然，他还与他至少一位被奴役的女性萨利·海明斯（Sally Hemings）保持着关系，并与她育有子女。因此，他对待奴隶制有着这种极其复杂且矛盾的态度，结果导致直到美国内战爆发时，南方白人对杰斐逊的态度都相当矛盾。对他们来说，他是一个真正成问题的政治人物。正如他们所称的，《独立宣言》中那些“光辉的普遍原则”，恰恰给他们带来了这些麻烦。
I mean, Jefferson, the author of the Declaration of Independence, all men are created equal, also himself a slaveholder, deeply conflicted, aware of the horrible bind that slavery puts people like him in. And of course, having a relationship with at least one of his enslaved women, Sally Hemings, and having children by her. And so has this deeply complex and ambivalent attitude to slavery, with the result that Jefferson himself, by the time of the American Civil War, white Southerners are quite ambivalent about Jefferson. He's a really problematic figure for them. The glittering generalities, as they call it, of the Declaration of Independence, which create these problems for
我的意思是，杰斐逊，作为《独立宣言》的起草人——“人人生而平等”——他自己也是一个蓄奴者，内心充满矛盾，深知奴隶制将像他这样的人置于何等可怕的困境之中。当然，他与自己的一名奴隶萨利·海明斯保持着关系，并与她育有子女。因此，他对奴隶制抱有一种极其复杂且矛盾的态度，结果导致在南北战争爆发前夕，南方白人对杰斐逊本人也相当矛盾。对他们来说，他是一个非常棘手的人物。《独立宣言》中那些被他们称为“闪光的空洞辞藻”的东西，给南方带来了这些问题……
people who by the 1860s need to rely on the idea that there is a cast iron difference between black people and white people because jeff jefferson there with that kind of famous um phrase about how he trembled for his country um reflecting that that god is just and that you know justice will be visited on it, which of course is essentially what happens. I think we should take a break at this point. When we come back, let's look at Abraham Lincoln and then let's look at the build up to war. host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of show biz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early
到了19世纪60年代，人们需要依赖黑人和白人之间存在天壤之别的观点，因为杰斐逊曾说过一句著名的名言，大意是说他为自己的国家感到颤抖，反映出上帝是公正的，你知道正义终将降临，而这当然也就是本质上发生的事情。我想我们现在应该休息一下。等我们回来，我们来看看亚伯拉罕·林肯，然后再来看看战争的蓄势。主持人：“The Rest Is Entertainment”是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦的阵营，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家附赠节目以及提前
access to live tickets head to the rest of entertainment.com that's the rest is history we're looking at the american civil war and more specifically in this first episode the causes of the american civil war um and in the first half adam we were talking about lincoln he's kind of popped up every so often as you might expect but we haven't really focused in on on who he is and why he becomes a significant player in the run-up to the civil war so just a bit of background on Lincoln I know this is absolutely your mastermind subject so if you could bear to just kind of compress it who is Lincoln what where's he coming from what motivates him why is he important well he grew up on the frontier he's born in 1809 in kentucky moved with his family to indiana moved on again eventually to illinois um he his family were poor about pretty much about as poor as you could get as a white family on the frontier had very little
购买现场门票的权限，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这就是The Rest Is History，我们正在探讨美国内战，更具体地说，在第一集里，我们将探讨美国内战的起因。在前半部分，亚当，我们一直在谈论林肯，正如你所料，他时不时地出现，但我们并没有真正关注他是谁，以及为什么他在内战前的时期成为一个重要角色。所以，关于林肯的背景，我知道这绝对是你的拿手好戏，如果你能把它精简一下，林肯是谁？他来自哪里？是什么促使了他？为什么他很重要？嗯，他在边境长大地长大，1809年出生于肯塔基州，随家人搬到印第安纳州，后来又搬到了伊利诺伊州。他的家庭很穷，作为边境地区的白人家庭，基本上穷得不能再穷了，几乎没有
formal education he learned to read and write he was estranged from his father at some point as a teenager and moved into a small community in Illinois, kind of pretty much on his own, and had to kind of build his own life, a war against Native Americans, didn't really fight, just fought mosquitoes by his own account. But that kind of elevated him in his own community because he was elected as an officer by his men and then found his way into the Illinois state legislature. He was, I mean, everybody who met Lincoln in those early years through the 1820s and 30s and 40s regarded him as fascinating and odd. I mean, in a hard-drinking world, he was a teetotaler. In a highly religious world, his own faith was ambivalent and shifting.
正规教育。他自学了读写。在青少年时期的某个时候，他与父亲疏远了，独自搬到了伊利诺伊州的一个小社区，不得不靠自己开创生活。他本没怎么参与对美洲原住民的战争，据他自己所说，只是跟蚊子战斗。但这在当地提升了他的声望，因为他被部下选为军官，随后进入了伊利诺伊州议会。我的意思是，在20世纪20、30和40年代早期，所有见过林肯的人都认为他既迷人又古怪。在一个酗酒成风的世界里，他滴酒不沾；在一个宗教气氛浓厚的社会里，他自己的信仰却模棱两可且摇摆不定。
And we can talk more about that. But definitely Christian-ish. Oh, certainly Christian-ish. I mean, he grew up in a kind of Baptist community, an anti-slavery Baptist community. And he mostly, although not always, attended church. I mean, this was a religious world, but he also wrote tracts questioning the existence of God at various moments when he was accused of infidelity, which was a political liability for him. I think he had a kind of Old Testament providentialism. I mean, he believed in an all controlling fate. And certainly
我们可以多谈谈这一点。但绝对算得上是基督徒吧？哦，当然算基督徒。我的意思是，他在一种浸信会社区长大，是一个反奴隶制的浸信会社区。他大部分时间（虽然不是全部时间）都去教堂。我的意思是，这是一个充满宗教信仰的世界，但当他被指控不忠时，他也曾在不同时期写过质疑上帝存在的小册子，这对他来说是个政治软肋。我认为他有一种旧约式的宿命论。我的意思是，他相信一种全能控制的命运，而且
by the time of the Civil War, he was deeply conscious of his own humility in the face of an all controlling providence, but he rarely talked about Christ. And a fate like the one that Jefferson was talking about just before the break, one that judges sin definitely definitely i mean you know i think his his his religious views were quite different from jefferson who was a product of the kind of deism of the 1770s and 1780s but but he he had a deep consciousness of sin and that came out that comes out most obviously in his extraordinary second inaugural address at the very end of his life in 1865, in which he talks about the sin of slavery and the
到了内战时期，他深深地意识到自己在全能天意面前的谦卑，但他很少谈论基督。就像杰斐逊在休息前谈到的那种命运，一种明确惩罚罪恶的命运……确实如此，你知道，我认为他的宗教观点与杰斐逊截然不同。杰斐逊是1770年代和1780年代自然神论的产物，但他对罪恶有着深深的意识，这最明显地体现在他1865年生命尽头时发表的非凡的第二次就职演说中，他在演说中谈到了奴隶制的罪恶，以及
punishment being inflicted on both North and South by God for the 200 years of bondage in America. But Adam, when you get to the 1850s, I mean, even in the early 1850s, let's say, Lincoln is surely at that point an exceedingly implausible person to become president of the United States, isn't he? I mean, he's a weak... Yeah, nobody would have heard of him. I mean, he was a one-term congressman.
上帝因美国两百年的奴役而对北方和南方施加的惩罚。但是，亚当，当你进入19世纪50年代时，比如哪怕是在50年代初，林肯在那个时候肯定是一个极其不可能成为美国总统的人，对吧？我的意思是，他是一个弱势……是的，没人会听说过他。我的意思是，他曾是一个任期只有一届的国会议员。
Yes, to get back to Lincoln in his life, Dominic, he was a one-term congressman from Illinois. He was actually there in Congress, able to oppose the Mexican war, but he introduced resolutions demanding that the spot on American soil in which the Mexicans had allegedly invaded be revealed by the president, knowing that there was no such spot so if somehow lincoln had kind of disappeared from the historical record in 1850 he might be remembered if at all as kind of spotty lincoln the man who who raised that question in congress in the face of an overwhelming pro-war majority um he did a few things in in illinois in the illinois state. He was always in a minority opposing. I mean, there was a
是的，回到林肯的生平，多米尼克，他曾是来自伊利诺伊州的一任国会议员。他当时确实在国会中反对美墨战争，但他提出了决议案，要求总统指出美军士兵据称遭到墨西哥人入侵的美国领土上的具体地点，因为他知道根本没有这样一个地方。因此，如果林肯在1850年从历史记录中消失的话，他最多也可能被当成“精确点林肯”（Spotty Lincoln）而被人们记住——那个在压倒性的主战多数面前，在国会提出那个问题的人。他在伊利诺伊州做过一些事情，在伊利诺伊州议会里，他总是属于少数反对派。我的意思是，当时有一个
resolution opposing the formation of abolitionist societies in Illinois, which passed overwhelmingly. And Lincoln was one of a minority of people who opposed that resolution. So where there was, in the odd occasion, the opportunity to stand up against slavery, Lincoln generally did so. But it wasn't at the center of his political project. At the center of his political project up through the early 1850s was probably banking. I mean, that was the thing that really mattered to him because he wanted to bring credit. He was a Whig. He was a Whig in a state that was the other thing. I mean, he was a teetotaler in a hard drinking state. He was a Whig in a democratic state. And so he wanted
反对在伊利诺伊州成立废奴主义社团的决议案，该决议以压倒性多数通过了。而林肯是少数反对该决议的人之一。因此，在偶尔有站出来反对奴隶制的机会时，林肯通常都会这么做。但这并不是他政治蓝图的核心。在1850年代初之前，他政治蓝图的核心可能是银行。我的意思是，那是他真正关心的事情，因为他想引入信贷。他是一名辉格党人。他是一个身处另一个政党州的辉格党人。我的意思是，他在一个酗酒成风的州里滴酒不沾，在一个民主党占优势的州里是个辉格党人。因此，他渴望
economic development. He wanted to increase the availability of credit so that people could start small businesses. And he wanted to imagine an economically diverse Illinois. That was the thing that really got him out of bed in the morning. For people not familiar with the intricacies of American party politics in the 90s. Are there any people like that? Well, including me. The system such as we recognize it now with Democrats and Republicans at this point does not exist. So it's Democrats and Whigs.
经济发展。他希望增加信贷的可得性，以便人们能够创办小企业。他希望构想一个经济多元化的伊利诺伊州。那是真正让他每天早晨起床的动力。对于不熟悉90年代美国党派政治复杂性的人来说，有这样的人吗？当然有，包括我在内。我们现在所认知的民主党和共和党并存的体系在当时并不存在，所以当时是民主党和辉格党的天下。
And is that essentially what the state of play is? Yeah. The Whig Party, the Democratic Party was really the world's first mass political party. It emerged really in support of Andrew Jackson, this great populist president who ran for office first in 1824 and was elected in 1828 and re-elected in 1832. And the Whigs were the opponents to the Jacksonian Democrats. They were never really very successful, to be honest, as a national political party. But insofar as there was a functioning two party system in the 1830s election, trying to repeat the trick of nominating a famous general from the Mexican war and hoping that he got elected despite the fact
局势基本上就是这样吗？是的。辉格党人，民主党实际上是世界上第一个群众性政党。它的出现是为了支持安德鲁·杰克逊这位伟大的民粹主义总统，他于1824年首次竞选公职，并在1828年当选，1832年连任。辉格党人则是杰克逊派民主党的反对者。说实话，作为全国性政党，他们从未真正取得过太大成功。但在1830年代的选举中，如果存在一个运作良好的两党制的话，他们会试图复制提名一位墨西哥战争著名将军的诡计，并希望他尽管身为辉格党人也能当选。
that he was a Whig. They failed in 1852 and were never able again to run a presidential candidate. And the collapse of the Whig Party, like the Democrats, a national political party which had the support of slaveholders in the South and non-slaveholders in the North, the collapse of the Whig Party created the political space for the rise of the Republican Party in the 1850s. The Republican Party being a northern anti-slavery party. We can talk about exactly how anti-slavery it was and what form its anti-slavery party we can talk about exactly how anti-slavery it was and what form its anti-slavery politics took but it was a northern anti-slavery party and that was the
他们在1852年失败了，此后再也无法推选出总统候选人。辉格党和民主党一样，是一个得到了南方蓄奴主义者和北方非蓄奴主义者支持的全国性政党，辉格党的崩溃为1850年代共和党的崛起创造了政治空间。共和党是一个北方的反奴隶制政党。我们可以讨论它到底有多反奴隶制，以及它的反奴隶制采取了什么形式……我们可以讨论它到底有多反奴隶制，以及它的反奴隶制政治采取了什么形式，但它确实是一个北方的反奴隶制政党，这就是
party that lincoln as many other wigs did as well lincoln joined in the mid 1850s and which eventually carried him into national power as the first republican president elected in 1860 so that's another turn of the ratchet if that's the right metaphor isn't it towards towards conflict because the republican party is an avowedly anti-slavery party and i guess to some extent maybe this is too simplistic is perceived as an anti-southern party i mean there are no southern republicans right no i mean the lincoln gets a handful of votes in kent a handful in Virginia, but essentially that's absolutely right. But basically a brave man if you come out as a Republican. You're a very brave
林肯（正如许多其他辉格党人所做的那样）在19世纪50年代中期加入的政党，这最终将他推上了国家权力的巅峰，使他在1860年当选为第一位共和党总统。所以，如果用这个比喻恰当的话，这又是朝着冲突迈出的关键一步，对吧？因为共和党是一个公开的反奴隶制政党，而且我想在某种程度上——也许这太简单化了——它被视为一个反南方的政党。我的意思是，南方没有共和党人，对吧？没有，我的意思是林肯在肯塔基州只得到了零星的选票，在弗吉尼亚州也只有零星的选票，但基本上完全如此。但如果你公开自己是共和党人，你基本上就是个勇士。如果你在那些地方公开自己是共和党人，你绝对是个非常勇敢的人，没错。这就是为什么，你知道，我们必须讨论选举制度。我的意思是，你知道，我们知道选举很重要，但游戏规则很重要，选举制度很重要。因此，尽管共和党甚至只试图在北方获得选票，它仍然是一个具有可行性的政党，因为选举人团选举总统的制度意味着，他们早在1856年首次尝试时就知道了——他们在1856年未能选出自己的候选人——但他们可以在1860年选出林肯，尽管在全国范围内林肯获得的普选票不到40%。但是，由于他在大多数情况下赢得了多数票，或者至少是多数（多于其他人）的票——在不蓄奴的北方各州赢得了多数选票，这给了他……如果你赢得了一个州，你就会获得该州所有的选举人团票（当时新泽西州是个有趣的外例，但暂且不论），你将赢得这些州所有的选举人团票。因此，他在1860年赢得了选举人团的大多数票，尽管他获得的全国普选票只是很小的
man if you come out as a Republican in those places, definitely, yes. And this is why, you know, we've got to talk about electoral systems. I mean, you know, we know that elections matter, but the rules of the game matter, electoral systems matter. So the Republican Party is a plausible party, despite only even attempting to get votes in the North, because the electoral college system for electing the president means that they know as early as 1856, when they try for the first time, they fail to elect their candidate in 1856, but they can elect Lincoln in 1860, even though nationally Lincoln gets less than 40% of the popular vote. But because he wins a majority, or at least a plurality, in most cases, the majority of the vote in the non-slaveholding northern states, that gives him, and if you win a state, you get all of the Electoral College votes, with the interesting exception of New Jersey at that time, but leaving that aside, you get all of the Electoral College votes, with the interesting exception of New Jersey at that time, but leaving that aside, you get all of the Electoral College votes from those states. And so he won a big majority in the Electoral College in 1860, despite winning only a small
少数。大家都知道这一点。如果没有这一点，如果采用不同的总统选举制度，共和党就不会是一个可行的组织，但它确实是。
minority of the national popular vote. Everybody knew that. Without that, with a different electoral system for president, the Republican Party would not have been a viable organization, but it was. So before we get to that point adam i mean obviously lincoln's election is is that is the trigger if i mean i've got my metaphors were over the shop i've had a ratchet i've got a trigger i've got i've got basically a toolbox it's not going well um no no i've got i've got a whole panoply of of metaphors tom i think is the is the truth of it a rising fever um, I've got a horrendous cold. So this is basically like a fever dream talking to Adam and Tom.
所以在我们谈到那一点之前，亚当，我的意思是，显然林肯的当选是导火索……如果……我的比喻真是乱七八糟，一会儿说棘轮，一会儿说导火索，一会儿又说工具箱，进展不太顺利……不，不，汤姆，说实话，我有一整套的比喻，一场不断升高的发烧……我得了可怕的感冒。所以和亚当、汤姆说话基本上就像是一场发烧梦。
But the temperature has been rising year on year, hasn't it? And let's, I mean, there's Kansas, there's the Dred Scott case, and there's John Brown. So let's do Kansas first. So basically, this is sort of paramilitary. It's kind of a civil war before the civil war isn't it within the state of kansas so there was a civil war in kansas before there was a civil war everywhere else because kansas was the latest place in which congress had to make a decision
但气温确实年复一年地在上升，对吧？比如，堪萨斯州事件、斯科特案（Dred Scott case），还有约翰·布朗（John Brown）。我们先聊聊堪萨斯州吧。所以基本上，这有点像是准军事性质的。在堪萨斯州境内，这有点像是一场内战前的内战，对吧？因此，在其他地方爆发内战之前，堪萨斯州就已经爆发了内战，因为堪萨斯州是国会必须做出决定的最新地区，
about whether slavery should exist or not so a bill came Congress at the very end of 1853 to organize Kansas as the United States territory. And everybody had thought up until then that the status of slavery in this part of North America would never be an issue because Congress had previously decided in what was called the Missouri Compromise that all future land north of the 36 degrees 30 parallel would be free territory and slavery would be allowed south of it. Now, this new proposed United States territory, which would later become a state, was north of that line, so slavery shouldn't exist. And yet, when the bill was brought forward, introduced into the Senate, it was introduced with a brand new provision that after all, the territorial
决定是否应该存在奴隶制。因此，在1853年底，国会提出了一项法案，将堪萨斯组织为美国领土。直到那时，所有人都认为，北美这一地区的奴隶制地位永远不会成为一个问题，因为国会此前在所谓的《密苏里妥协案》（Missouri Compromise）中决定，北纬36度30分以北的所有未来土地都将是自由领土，而其以南则允许存在奴隶制。现在，这个新提议的美国领土（后来将成为一个州）位于该线以北，所以本不应该存在奴隶制。然而，当该法案被提交并引入参议院时，其中加入了一条全新条款：毕竟，这块新领土的领土
legislature of this new territory would determine for itself whether or not slavery existed. For anti-slavery Northerners, this was an extraordinary betrayal. This was upending what they had thought was for a generation, for more than 30 years, had been the settled policy. And it looked like an incredible act of aggression by the slave power, as they called it. The guy who introduced the bill, Stephen Douglas, Democratic senator from Illinois, long-term sparring partner of Abraham Lincoln, he himself is from a northern state, from a non-slaveholding state in Illinois. He said, look, this is no big deal. Slavery probably isn't going to go into Kansas anyway. Who's going to want to take slaves into Kansas? You're never going to be able to really grow cotton there successfully. This is just a pragmatic way of making sure this bill passes.
立法机构将自行决定是否存在奴隶制。对于反奴隶制的北方人来说，这是一种非同寻常的背叛。这颠覆了他们认为已经维持了一代人、超过30年的既定政策。在他们看来，这像是蓄奴势力的一次极其激进的侵略行为。提出该法案的人是史蒂芬·道格拉斯（Stephen Douglas），来自伊利诺伊州的民主党参议员，也是亚伯拉罕·林肯长期的辩论对手。他本人来自北方的一个州，来自伊利诺伊州这个不蓄奴的州。他说：“听着，这没什么大不了的。奴隶制反正也不太可能会进入堪萨斯。谁会想把奴隶带到堪萨斯去呢？你在那里永远也无法真正成功种植棉花。这只是一种确保该法案通过的务实方法。
My Southern colleagues really want this. Let's give it to them. Slavery isn't going to exist in Kansas anyway, so let's all just calm down about it. And insofar as this is a positive resolution of the question of slavery, what can be more more american it's popular sovereignty in action just let people decide who could possibly object they choose that people of kansas choose freely for themselves yeah slavery or not slavery but then what happened dominic was that people piled in with guns to fight it out on the ground so this is bleeding kansas bleeding kansas yeah right and it was horrible and and one of the people who went there to fight for the free state cause was this guy, John Brown, an abolitionist who'd been radicalized 15 years earlier and who committed one of the many atrocities that were committed in 1850s Kansas and went on from there to lead in 1859
我的南方同事们真的很想要这个，我们就满足他们吧。反正堪萨斯也不会有奴隶制，所以大家还是冷静点吧。”既然这是对奴隶制问题的一个积极解决办法，还有什么比这更美国化的呢？这就是行动中的大众主权，让人民自己决定，谁会反对呢？他们选择让堪萨斯人民自由自主地决定——是的，是要奴隶制还是不要奴隶制？但接下来发生的事，多米尼克，就是人们带着枪蜂拥而至，在实地上一决高这就是“流血的堪萨斯”（Bleeding Kansas）。“流血的堪萨斯”，没错，太可怕了。其中一个去那里为自由州事业而战的人就是这个家伙——约翰·布朗，一个在15年前就已经激进化并犯下了1850年代堪萨斯发生的众多暴行之一的废奴主义者，他后来还在1859年领导了
an attempted insurrection of enslaved people in Virginia. So John Brown, I mean, he's stereotypically, you see him, he's this incredibly forbidding looking bloke with a colossal beard, isn't he? Yeah, Old Testament prophet type. Who lies among his grave. Yeah, exactly. Old Testament prophet with gun. yeah yeah old pro old testament prophet type who lies in his grave yeah exactly old testament prophet with gun um but i mean how should is he is he a terrorist or is he a freedom fighter
一次弗吉尼亚州被奴役人民的起义未遂。所以约翰·布朗，我的意思是，他给人的典型印象是——你看到他时，他是一个长相极其严厉、留着巨大胡子的家伙，对吧？是的，旧约先知那种类型。长眠于地下。对，没错。带有枪支的旧约先知。
because he's fighting on behalf of the slaves but as you say he's he's carried out atrocities in kansas he's launched he launches this rebellion doesn't it harper's ferry virginia yeah 1859 which gets suppressed by um a very distinguished u.s uh military man called robert e lee yes he's a colonel at the time yes who that's right the well is he a terrorist or a freedom fighter i mean that's that's you could ask that about most um about most people in history try to use violence uh to achieve ends right i mean he believes that he is being appointed by god to rid the united states of the sin of slavery and that any means will justify that end yeah but isn't also the key thing about brown and why he has such an impact is that he doesn't die when lee and his men come and recapture the whatever it is the um the arsenal
对，对，旧约先知类型的人，长眠于地下。对，没错，带枪的旧约先知。但是，我的意思是，我们该如何看待他？他是一个恐怖分子还是一个自由斗士？因为他是为了奴隶们的利益而战，但正如你所说，他在堪萨斯实施了暴行，他发动了这场叛乱，不是吗？弗吉尼亚州的哈珀斯费里（Harpers Ferry），对吧，1859年，结果被一个非常杰出的美国军事人物罗伯特·E·李（Robert E. Lee）给镇压了。是的，他当时是个上校，没错，就是那个……那么，他是恐怖分子还是自由斗士？我的意思是，你对历史上大多数试图使用暴力来达到目的的人都可以问这个问题，对吧？我的意思是，他相信自己是被上帝委任来清除美国奴隶制这一罪恶的，任何手段都可以证明这一目的的正当性。是的，但关于布朗以及他为什么有如此巨大影响的关键点不也在于，当李和他的手下前来重新夺回那个……无论那是什么……那个武器库时，他没有死吗？
the arsenal that he's captured he he gets taken prisoner and so he has his time in the dock yeah and because he's an old testament kind of guy you put an old testament kind of guy in the dock and he really lets rip yeah the biblical language yeah and. Yeah. And then he is sentenced to death and he's hung. And on the day of his hanging, the bells toll once again in Boston and in the the unitarian congregations and the congregationalist congregations meet together to mourn the death of someone who they certainly regard as a freedom fighter and that his soul is marching on yeah but that absolutely inflames the south doesn't it because as far as they see it the northerners are in bed with this as they would say terrorist yeah and do
他被俘虏了，因此他有了在被告席上陈述的时间。是的，因为他是个旧约先知型的人物，你把一个旧约先知型的人物放到被告席上，他就会彻底爆发，对吧？那种圣经语言。是的，然后他被判处死刑并被绞死。在他被绞死的日子里，波士顿的钟声再次敲响，一神论者会众和公理会会众聚集在一起，哀悼一个他们绝对视作自由斗士的人的死亡，并高唱“他的灵魂在行进”。是的，但这绝对激怒了南方，不是吗？因为在他们看来，北方人与这个他们眼中的“恐怖分子”勾结在了一起。你觉得在那时——也就是说在1850年代……还有其他一些事情发生了，对吧？因为参议院也发生过暴力事件，众议员普雷斯顿·布鲁克斯（Preston Brooks）用手杖袭击了一个叫查尔斯·萨姆纳（Charles Sumner）的家伙，对吧，亚当？
you think at that point so in 18 so there's been a couple of other things haven't there because there's been there's been violence in the senate um a representative preston brooks has attacked yeah with a cane a bloke called charles charles sumner isn't it, Adam? Yeah, yeah. Charles Sumner, who was a Massachusetts senator, anti-slavery senator. Yeah, he gets attacked with a cane and almost killed. I mean, he's unconscious and lying on the floor with blood seeping out of his skull, and this guy Preston Brooks keeps on smashing his stick into the back of his head.
对，对。查尔斯·萨姆纳，马萨诸塞州参议员，反奴隶制参议员。对，他遭到手杖袭击，差点丧命。我的意思是，他昏迷不醒地躺在地板上，头骨流血，而这个叫普雷斯顿·布鲁克斯的家伙还在不停地用手杖猛砸他的后脑勺。
So a real sense that the centre is not holding, that violence is kind of lapping at the feet of the Republic. And then you have Lincoln's election. And does a combination of all this mean that essentially by this point, there is no stopping it? The war is inevitable. It's just a matter of time. When Lincoln is elected.
所以有一种强烈的感觉，即政治中心已经失守，暴力正在拍打着共和国的基石。然后就迎来了林肯的当选。所有这些因素结合在一起，是否意味着基本上到了这个时候，已经无法阻挡了？战争是不可避免的，只是时间问题？当林肯当选时。
I think that's probably true, that by by this point some kind of confrontation is inevitable whether it's the war that actually happened is it is a different question of course they're all different kinds of uh scenarios even once secession has happened and once the the military has been engaged but that some kind of breakdown is going to happen i think i think that's right. And I think all of this is important to remembering that, I mean, I see, I mean, there are many historians who disagree with me on this, but I see Lincoln as in some ways fundamentally quite a conservative figure of the small C.
我想这大概是真的，到这个时候，某种形式的对抗已经是不可避免的了。至于这是否就是后来实际发生的战争，当然是另一个问题。即使是在分裂已经发生、军队已经交战之后，也存在着各种不同类型的设想，但某种形式的崩溃将会发生，我想这是对的。而且我认为，所有这些对于记住这一点都很重要——我的意思是，我知道有许多历史学家在这方面与我有分歧——但我认为林肯在某些方面基本上是一个相当保守的小c保守主义人物。
I mean, he is deeply anti-slavery. He's deeply concerned about the institutions and preserving the republic. And he sees, as do millions of other northerners that slavery leads to lawlessness and violence that's how he sees it and he sees the slave power making these authoritarian grabs for national power passing the fugitive slave act and then dominic the thing you you just mentioned in passing the the dred scott decision yeah um the supreme court in 1857 um rules in this uh case of a of an enslaved person who sues for his freedom
我的意思是，他极其反对奴隶制，极其关注制度并致力于维护共和国。他看到——正如数百万其他北方人所看到的那样——奴隶制导致了无政府状态和暴力，他是这样看的。他看到蓄奴势力为了夺取国家权力而进行这些专制掠夺，通过了《逃亡奴隶法》（Fugitive Slave Act），然后呢，多米尼克，就是你刚才顺便提到的那件事——斯科特案裁决（Dred Scott decision），是的。最高法院在1857年对这个案件做出了裁决——一个被奴役的人为了争取自由而提起诉讼，
on the grounds that his owner took him into a uh free territory and so therefore he should have been freed and the and the and the supreme court basically says um no no you you can't be freed just because you're in a free territory because that would be to violate the fifth amendment rights of your owner in other words slavery is is property and you can't take someone's property away without due process of law and that implies doesn't it that slavery can never be got rid of is that right yeah and and and what basis then can a state like massachusetts uh ban slavery if it's a constitutional right if if slavery is property then you cannot be deprived of your property as a united states citizen then you know the next as lincoln called it the next dred scott decision may well say that a slaveholder can go into Massachusetts and legally hold his slaves there and potentially buy and sell slaves there.
理由是他的主人把他带到了一片自由领土上，因此他应该获得自由。而最高法院基本上表示：“不，不，你不能仅仅因为身处自由领土就获得自由，因为那将侵犯你主人的第五修正案权利。”换句话说，奴隶制是财产，未经正当法律程序，你不能剥夺别人的财产。这不就暗示了吗？奴隶制永远无法被根除，是这样吗？是的。那么，如果奴隶制是一项宪法权利，马萨诸塞州这样的州凭什么可以禁止奴隶制？如果奴隶制是财产，作为美国公民，你不能被剥夺你的财产，那么正如林肯所说，接下来的下一个斯科特案裁决很可能会说，一个奴隶主可以进入马萨诸塞州，并在那里合法地拥有他的奴隶，甚至可能在那里买卖奴隶。
Who knows? I mean, thin end of the wedge. The implication of that is that, you know, and this goes back to where we began with this conversation, that the problem is basically within the Constitution itself. It's within the very foundational documents of the American Republic. Yeah. And that obviously makes it very difficult to sort out. Yeah. So could we, I think that we have, I mean,
谁知道呢？这就是温水煮青蛙（事情的恶化）。其隐含之意是——这又回到了我们这次对话的起点——问题基本上存在于宪法本身之中，存在于美利坚共和国最根本的奠基文件中。是的，这显然使得事情很难解决。是的。所以我们能不能……我认为我们已经……
this has been absolutely tour de force looking at the buildup to the war. Adam, could you just take us from Lincoln's election to when the first shots are fired, and then tomorrow we'll look at the opening stages of the war. Yeah, so Lincoln was elected in November 1860. And immediately, the state of South Carolina, which is always in the vanguard of Southern radicalism, immediately the state of South Carolina started making preparations to secede from the Union, to leave the United States. And they did that. By December, they'd already done done that and they sent out emissaries to other slaveholding
这是一次绝对精彩绝伦的梳理，回顾了战争的蓄势。亚当，你能带我们从林肯当选一直讲到第一声枪响吗？明天我们将探讨战争的初期阶段。好的，林肯于1860年11月当选。南卡罗来纳州立刻——该州一直是南方激进主义的先锋——南卡罗来纳州立刻开始筹备脱离联邦，离开美国。他们确实这么做了。到了12月，他们已经完成了这一步，并向其他蓄奴的
southern states to encourage them to do likewise by the time lincoln was inaugurated in march 1861 seven slaveholding states had left the union and that's illegal well we should come to that so we'll come to that in the next episode we can we can i mean yes they certainly they certainly thought it was a perfectly legitimate thing to do they had voluntarily entered into this union just as britain voluntarily entered into the european union and they were voluntarily getting out of it because the terms of uh of the deal had apparently changed they were taking back control adam they were taking back control, Adam. They were taking back control. And they said this very explicitly in the manifestos, as it were, their documents they issued to explain secession. So by the time Lincoln became president, he had this,
南方州派遣了特使，鼓励它们效仿。到1861年3月林肯就职时，已经有七个蓄奴州离开了联邦。这合法吗？嗯，我们应该谈谈这个。我们会在下一集里讨论这个。我们可以……我的意思是，是的，他们当然……他们当然认为这是一个完全合法的事情。他们是自愿加入这个联邦的，就像英国自愿加入欧盟一样，他们现在自愿退出，因为交易的条款显然已经改变了。亚当，他们正在夺回控制权。亚当，他们正在夺回控制权。他们正在夺回控制权。他们在宣言中非常明确地表达了这一点，也就是他们为解释脱离联邦而发布的那些文件中。因此，当林肯成为总统时，他面对的是一种
it was a kind of Cold War standoff. There were these seven states that by then had formed an independent confederacy, had put people on ships sending them over to paris and to london to demand to request diplomatic recognition from europe they had adopted a new flag uh they had written a new constitution which was unnervingly similar in every respect to the united states constitution except for the fact that it explicitly said that slavery was allowed it also gave the president six a six-year term, interestingly, and a line item veto, but that's too geeky, I think, possibly for this podcast. It was essentially the same. And they
类似于冷战对峙的局面。当时已有七个州组成了一个独立的邦联，并派人乘船前往巴黎和伦敦，要求获得欧洲的外交承认。他们采用了一面新国旗，起草了一部新宪法——这部宪法在各个方面都与美国宪法惊人地相似，除了它明确规定奴隶制是合法的。有趣的是，它还将总统任期定为六年，并赋予了针对特定项目的否决权（line-item veto），但我认为对于这个播客来说，这可能有点太极客了。它基本上是一样的。而且他们
revered Washington. And they said, we are basically the continuity USA. The United States has betrayed its founding principles. It set up this um government which is not upholding our property rights so we haven't we haven't left the united states we haven't left the united states the united states has left us exactly and new capital at richmond virginia yeah well at that not at that time not at that time they were in montgomery alabama but then there was only seven states uh seceded at that point then what happens is there's a question well what about federal property so there were you know mints and lots of military installations and dozens of them all across the south most of them were taken over by the states as they seceded but there were a couple for which that was rather harder. And one of them was Fort Sumter, which is on an island in
崇敬华盛顿。他们说：“我们基本上是美国（USA）的延续。美国已经背叛了它的立国原则。它建立了一个不维护我们财产权的政府，所以我们没有离开美国，我们没有离开美国，是美国离开了我们。”没错。新首都设在弗吉尼亚州的里士满？嗯，当时还没有，当时还没有，他们当时在阿拉巴马州的蒙哥马利。但那时只有七个州脱离了联邦。接下来发生的问题是：联邦财产怎么办？因为你知道，南方各地有铸币厂、许多军事设施，大大小小几十处。其中大部分在各州脱离时被接管了，但有几个地方比较难办。其中之一就是萨姆特堡（Fort Sumter），它位于南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿港的一个岛屿上。那个岛上只有一个很小的守备队。南卡罗来纳人要求其投降。问题是：新的林肯政府应该允许这种投降吗？当然不，他们绝不会这么做。他们还能怎么办？也许他们会派增援部队……当然不会这么做。他们还能怎么办？也许他们只是去重新补给，因为不能再直接从查尔斯顿进行补给。所以你派一艘船去，让守备队多坚持一会儿。但在你这么做之前，南卡罗来纳人开火了。所以他们直接向美国国旗开火了。星条旗在萨姆特堡上空飘扬。他们迫使萨姆特堡投降。作为对此的回应，林肯下令征召军队。他向所有州征召志愿者。他致信弗吉尼亚州州长、肯塔基州州长以及蓄奴州的州长，说：“正在发生叛乱。”作为三军统帅，他征召了志愿者。作为对这一举措的回应，上南方各州——包括最重要、人口最多、经济价值最高的弗吉尼亚州——不得不作出抉择。它是要派兵去镇压南卡罗来纳州的这场叛乱，还是与南方的兄弟们站在一起？嗯，它选择了后者。因此弗吉尼亚州也宣布独立，邦联首都随后迁至里士满，而里士满距离华盛顿特区以南当然只有大约90英里。好吧，亚当，在这个重磅炸弹般的时刻……字面意义上的重磅炸弹。字面意义上的重磅炸弹。非常感谢你分享这些。我想我们就在这里休息一下。在下一集里，我们将探讨战争的爆发。
Charleston Harbor in South Carolina. There's a very small garrison in that island. And the South Carolinians demanded its surrender. And the question is, should the new Lincoln administration allow this surrender? Well, no, of course, they're not going to do that. What can they do instead? Maybe they send reinforce, of course they're not going to do that. What can they do instead? Maybe they send reinforcements. Maybe they just resupply it because it can't be resupplied directly from Charleston anymore. So you send a ship to keep the garrison going for a bit longer. But before you could do that, the South Carolinians opened fire. So they literally opened fire on the American flag. The Stars and Stripes was flying over Fort Sumter. They forced the surrender of Fort Sumter. And in response to that, Lincoln called for troops. He called for volunteers from all of the states. He sent to the governor of Virginia, to the governor of Kentucky, to slaveholding states. He said, there's an insurrection going on. And as commander in chief, he called up volunteers. In response to that, then the upper
位于南卡罗来纳州的查尔斯顿港。该岛上有一个非常小的守备部队。南卡罗来纳州人要求其投降。问题是，新上任的林肯政府是否应该允许这种投降？当然不会，他们绝不会这么做。那他们还能做什么呢？也许他们会派增援部队……当然他们不会这么做。那他们还能做什么呢？也许他们只是去重新补给，因为已经无法再从查尔斯顿直接获得补给。所以你派了一艘船去让守军多坚持一会儿。但在此之前，南卡罗来纳州人开火了。所以他们真的向美国国旗开火了。星条旗当时正飘扬在萨姆特堡上空。他们迫使萨姆特堡投降。作为对此的回应，林肯下令征召军队。他向所有州征召志愿者。他致信弗吉尼亚州州长、肯塔基州州长以及蓄奴州的州长。他说，发生了一场叛乱。作为三军统帅，他召集了志愿者。作为对此的回应，随后上南部的……
South states, including the most important and the most populous, the most economically valuable one of Virginia, had to choose. Was it going to send troops to suppress this rebellion in South Carolina, or was it going to stand alongside its southern brethren? Well, it chose the latter. And so Virginia seceded as well, and the Confederate capital was then moved to Richmond, which of course is only about 90 miles due south of Washington, DC. Well, Adam, on that bombshell. That literal bombshell. Literal bombshell. Thanks so much for that. I think we will take a break here. In the next episode, we will look at the opening of the war.
包括其中最重要、人口最多、经济价值最高的弗吉尼亚州在内的南方各州，不得不做出选择。它是要派兵去镇压南卡罗来纳州的这场叛乱，还是要与南方的兄弟们站在一起？嗯，它选择了后者。因此，弗吉尼亚州也宣布独立，随后邦联首都迁至里士满，而里士满距离华盛顿特区以南当然只有大约90英里。好的，亚当，伴随着这个重磅炸弹。字面意义上的重磅炸弹。字面意义上的重磅炸弹。非常感谢你为我们带来这些。我想我们就在这里休息一下。在下一集中，我们将探讨战争的开端。
So please join us then for this most extraordinary of stories. Our thanks to Adam. Thanks to you for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
请大家届时收听这个极其非凡的故事。感谢亚当。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取独家附赠节目、提前收听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishtertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishtertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。